[موسيقى]
اكثر من ثمانين الفن نجوا من الزلزال
المدمره في تركيا استمرار العثور على
ناجين في اليوم الثامن للكارثه زعيم كوريا
الشماليه يمنع تسميه البنات باسم ابنته
هذه الاخبار هو غيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا
بكم رغم تلاشى الامال بالعثور على نجيم
تستمر عمليه الانقاذ في اليوم الثامن
لوقوع الزلزال المدمر الذي خلف اكثر من 37
الف قتيل في تركيا وسوريا حتى الان في
الاثناء اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ان حوالي 81 الف مصاب نجوا من
الزلزال مشيرا الى ان جزءا كبيرا منهم
غادروا المستشفيات بعد تلقي العلاجه واضاف
اردوغان ان سلطات بلاده تعمل على ازاله
حطام الالاف من المباني المدمره نتيجه
الزلزال الذي وصفه باحد اكبر الكوارث
الطبيعيه ليست في تركيا فقط ولكن ايضا في
تاريخ البشريه
بعد مرور 198 ساعه على وقوع الزلزال
المدمر افدت وكاله انباء الاناضول التركيه
بانقاذ ثلاثه اشخاص من تحت الانقاذ في
البلاد في تفاصيل نجحت فرق الانقاذ والبحث
في اخراج شقيقين شابين من تحت الانقاد
بولايه كهرما المرعش وتم نقلهما مباشره
الى العلاج في المستشفى فيما جرى انقاذ
شخص ثالث في ولايه اديمان جنوب تركيا وسط
معلومات تتحدث عن انقاذ السيده بعد مرور
204 ساعات في انطاكيا اما في سوريا فاعلن
الدفاع المدني استمرار عمليه البحث عن
ناجين في اليوم الثامن من وقوع الكارثه
قدر اتحاد الشركات والاعمال في تركيا حجم
الخسائر خسائر الزلزال المدمر بنحو 84
مليار دولار متوقعا ارتفاع عجز الموازنه
من 3.5 الى 5.4% على الاقل وكانت نقلت عن
بيان للاتحاد التركي بان الزلزال العنيف
تسبب في دمار مبان سكنيه بنحو 70.8 مليار
دولار اضافه الى 10 مليار دولار اخرى في
صوره خساره في الدخل القومي فيما قد تكلف
هذه الخسائر في القوى العامله اقتصاد
تركيا نحو 2.9 مليار دولار اذ ضرب الزلزال
عشر قطاعات تركيه واثر بقوه على ملايين
الاشخاص
بعد ايام على اسقاطه في المحيط الاطلسي
اعلن الجيش الامريكي عن انتشال اجزاء
كبيره من اجهزه الاستشعار والالكترونيات
التي كانت موجوده على متن المنقاد الصني
القياده الشماليه الامريكيه اوضحت في بيان
ان فرق البحث انتشرت كميه حطان كبيره من
الموقع بما في ذلك جميع الاجهزه اجهزه
الاستشعار ذات الاولويه وقطع الكترونيه
جرى تحدثها في مقاله امريكا ان المنطاد
كان يستخدم لاغراض التجسس ودخل اجوائها
قبل ايام من اسقاطه تؤكد الصين انه منطاد
مدني يستخدم لاغراض الطقس
وفي خبرنا الاخير كتبت صحيفه بزنس انسايدر
في تقرير لها ان زعيم كوريا الشماليه
اصدر قرارا يمنع النساء او الفتيات من
تسميه انفسهن باسم ابنته
القرار تضمن ايضا انه يجب على كل انثى
تحمل هذا الاسم الذهاب لمكتب تسجيل
الاسماء وتغييره اذ لا تستطيع اي عائله من
الان بعد صدور القرار اطلاق هذا الاسم على
اي مولود جديد فيما اكدت وسائل الاعلام
النابيون يونغ تجبر الاشخاص على تغيير
اسمائهم كجزء من جهود النظام لتكريم
الفتاه الصغيره التي من المتوقع ان تصبح
الزعيم القادم للبلد